la presidenta Dina boluarte dijo que
sujeción ha avanzado en garantizar el
orden democrático recuperar la
estabilidad y también en enfocar la
atención a las necesidades más urgentes
la mandataria señaló que Perú se
encuentra en la vitrina de los
inversionistas extranjeros tras la
crisis política y social que sufrió esa
nación en los primeros meses de este año
la mandataria reveló que de enero a mayo
Perú registra más de tres mil
ochocientos millones de dólares en
inversión pública y tras criticar a sus
adversarios la jefa de estado dijo que
la violencia no produce nada y por eso
pidió a los líderes de otros partidos
ser portadores de la paz y no de la
violencia la presidenta boluarte también
fue enfática al desmarcarse de la
corrupción y dijo que en su gestión
ningún ministro viceministro ni el
Primer Ministro ni la presidenta venga
al Perú como una bolsa para enriquecerse